I only thing I know I do which again
sounds very cliche is that I just work
hard and I'm very focused honestly
speaking I think I keep it very simple
is I've always kept it very simple I now
I start telling everyone I don't use the
film the film scuse me there's no such
thing as normal normal is just another
word for lifeless yeah be yourself
because everybody else is taken it fans
are like how you feel in front of an
ocean if you had been successfully
playing an angry young man you'd pretty
much be angry any young for the rest of
your life a king is not how much he
takes a king is how much he gives I have
a disease I'm a workaholic and it is
like being an alcoholic I just can't
give it up please remember me as someone
who tried and tried very hard he's an
Indian actor producer and television
personality he's often referred to as
the king of Bollywood and he's been more
than 80 Bollywood films winning numerous
accolades he's been described as one of
the most successful film stars in the
world
he's Shahrukh Khan and here is top 10
rules for success I've never understood
why I have become a big star I the only
thing I know I do which again sounds
very cliche is that I just work hard and
I'm very focused and I don't look at
anything else
there is no peripheral that is important
to me the parties are not important I'm
thankful for them the posters are not
important I'm grateful for them the
media is not important but I love them
because they've been very kind to me for
me what has happened is that that one
shot that I give in front of the camera
that is important and for last 16 years
totally focused absolute I just love
doing that I love saying Don koppikhar
namuci Lina Hina Monken I love it I
can't explain it I mean I'm I'm 40 years
old before t1 in about a month's time
less than a month's time but the
excitement I have of giving that one
punch
you know when I'm shooting that film
getting that kick ride or saying
something silly has a senorita it just
turns me on I love it I love it I get so
excited I become like a kid and I I'm I
just love the whole you know the camera
starts and then we look at this guy
angrily I love that angry look yeah and
I think I do it once more I live for
that I live for every second that I give
that shot on and I really enjoy
honestly speaking I think I keep it very
simple is I've always kept it very
simple so I wake up in the morning and
I'm like can I get that one shot right
like I thought 20 years ago now I hope I
get that shot right and I keep telling
my wife you know I find it in him 44 now
and I wear makeup to work hey maybe your
husband's here but but I find it that
you know I've kept it so simple I'm not
bothered about you know what I'm going
to do through the world of cinema for
the world no I just want to make a film
in which I am able to tell you a good
story so I think that really keeping it
simple and keeping it real like everyone
says a lot of people in America keep it
simple keep it real I think that really
is the mantra nothing else I have a
simple way that I work I just work very
hard
I hear a lot of stories and more than
the story I just like the people who
making a film and I socal do it I think
at least in films creatively the secret
of the success is that I I just feel the
goodness into it I have no other reason
I'm not very calculating about the film
that I'm doing I'll be lying if I say I
get sentimental about a film that's why
I do it I would be lying if I say a
certain topic touches me and is close to
me that's why I do it I don't know I
just do it believing in lot of goodness
and I say okay he or she believes it
looks very honest about it like I
haven't signed a new film I've had
offers from some really nice filmmakers
and some really nice and professional
scripts and I'm not decided and then
suddenly somebody tell me thats why I do
some films which go wrong also
I've never calculated what kind of film
to do and I think maybe that's why
whatever the powers-that-be
say okay he's doing it with a good heart
so let's just make it do well I'm quite
surprised with the kind of acumen I have
for choosing scripts
I have lasted for so long and that also
I believe I guess the people who I now I
start telling everyone I don't choose
the films the films choose me so it's
easier to answer a question like this I
don't choose that they choose me so I am
and I just try my best to do it but and
it works it has what every year I end up
having God has been kind every year I
end up having a film which does very
very well and for years I've been on
charts with the number one for number
two for number three film and I'm like
okay as a matter of fact it's a now
strange if I don't make a hit film every
year so I feel like oh so there was not
enough goodness so I'd kind be better
next year and try to spread that kind of
goodness and I truly believe I tell
everyone it's a little spiritual with me
now so it just okay this is nice let's
just do it
and I play it very easy I don't
concentrate too much I don't think too
much I don't believe too much I just do
it and it turns out right madness of the
particularly nice or romantic kind is an
absolute prerequisite to a happy and
successful life don't ever treat your
little insanities as of their
aberrations that ought to be hidden from
the rest of the world acknowledge them
and use them to define your own way of
living the only life you have all the
most beautiful people in the world the
most creative the ones who led
revolutions who discover and invented
things did so because they embraced
their own idiosyncrasies there's no such
thing as normal normal is just another
word for lifeless don't try to be
someone else you always find someone
better taller cooler handsomer nicer
more talented with better six-packs but
please do not try to be someone else
because I think it takes away the two
greatest gifts when you try to keep up
with others it takes away the two
greatest gifts life has given you one is
the freedom to fail and the ability to
say with your head held high I don't
know so like someone again has said I've
taken lot of coats this evening to be
appropriate
yeah be yourself because everybody else
is taken it's very important to do to be
who you are and and and you know try and
achieve things on your own go buy a
heart I know very truly have not a
genius
I'm very clearly not gifted and I know
that the position I've reached is a
position that should be given to a
genius it's not it's not deservingly so
so the reason I'm good to fans or I
believe in them is because one I'm
employed by them so I'm like thank you
guys you've been kind to me so I'm
returning that kindness or the second
way to look at if it is that okay listen
I'm really scared don't go anywhere
because I know I don't deserve it but
thank you so much so in hasta con I'm
just being uh I'm ready say I'm being
kind to them for my own selfish gains
but whatever the case I'm immensely
grateful I think it comes out of
gratitude it doesn't come out of any
other reason if I see on weekends I have
hundreds of people outside my house
today Sunday and a lot of people will
come out in the evening and I feel like
going and meeting them all my security
with the gun says don't but I want to
meet them because you know I'm like I
have to thank them so I think fans are
like how you feel in front of an ocean
you know sometimes when you are so full
of yourself you go down on a beach and
stand in front of the sea and realize
how insignificant you are and you know
all the importance in your house in your
well upholstered rooms and your louisvil
Thrones and your you know BMWs and
you're like oh god I'm so powerful and
then you go and stand in front of the
sea and you realize you're such an
insignificant nobody in the larger
scheme of things a fans to me are like
that see when I see them I realize my
insignificance without them I want to go
and stand with them and say okay I'm
insignificant but thank you for making
me so significant for making me so
special but twenty years ago in the
movies rules are very clearly defined
they provided the security of your
stardom in a sense if you'd been
successfully playing an angry young man
you'd pretty much be angry and young for
the rest of your life if you've been a
police inspector in three movies odds
were you'd be in the next 33 - this
applied to female actresses also wives
or wives seductresses were seductresses
mother-in-law's or mother-in-law's and
so on and so forth
few actors would have willingly switched
from romantic heroes to obsessively
violence levels I took the leap not
because I was particularly brave but
because a very
dear director friend of mine sat me down
and told me I was extremely ugly and
being ugly necessarily meant I know now
I know and being ugly necessarily meant
I do bad guy roles I wasn't the romantic
hero types he said actually he used the
words that my face was not chocolaty
enough so I started to eat a lot of
chocolate and while waiting for it to
take effect I jumped into bad guy roles
there means fair in Hindi and everyone
always tells you at speeches like this
that you ought to be brave so I'm not
going to bore you with that idea instead
let me tell you this being brave means
being [ __ ] scared all the way to the
party yeah I'm sorry if that word is
being very scared all the way to the
body but getting there but getting there
all the same and doing the Funky Chicken
in front of all your teenage kids
friends anyway let me just add on on
behalf of all the fathers of the world
who have embarrassed the kids by doing
this it takes a lot of bravery resolve
and grit to do it so just do it don't
let your fears become boxes that enclose
you open them out feel them and turn
them into the greatest courage you are
capable of I promise you nothing will go
wrong
but if you live by your fears everything
that can pass possibly go wrong will go
wrong and you won't even have done the
funky tea tea I like to tell everyone
and people who are not even as old as I
am that see the success is very
subjective when I decided to become an
actor my logic was see I'm going to give
it the best shot make a lot of people
smile along the way what happened is I
started making too many people smile and
I realize I don't deserve this so I
don't know how long am I going to last
but my wish and desire is that at the
end of my career I don't owe this to
anyone including the audience I'm able
to say listen I deserved it because I
gave you back enough people say I'm King
Khan which i think is a clever
journalistic alliteration but I totally
believe a king is not how much he earns
a king is not how much he takes a king
is how much he gives I believe success
no finish line and so I don't think I
have anything I have a disease I'm a
workaholic and it is like being an
alcoholic I just can't give it up
I've been unwell for two weeks and I
feel unwell
you know saikhan would work because I
can't go to work I get worse if I sit in
one place I'm stressed
the reason I'm not fidgeting too much is
because I want otherwise I hate sitting
in one place I some work has to be given
to me I mean my wife and my children
keep telling me you know you work 20
years round-the-clock why are you doing
this I don't think I need the money I
don't think I am greedy for more Fame
I'm doing okay I can do one film two
years and be happy with it but I'm just
not happy I tell everyone if I'm not
working I'm depressed so I don't know if
it's a curse or a blessing maybe at the
end of it all when we die God will say
did you work
I say yes a lot oh damn you go to hell
because I didn't want anyone to work oh
it would be oh you work that's really
nice because I wanted everyone to work
so I don't know one of them is going to
be right but I just keep working I think
I have this fear that you have very few
days in life and you need to clam it up
with lot of things you need to fit it
fit it with so many things in it that
you don't have space for life it should
be like that I when I'm not working I
get lonely I get depressed I get sad I
don't drink I'm not a philosopher I'm
not a poet that I like loneliness I hate
being alone and I hate being with people
at times
I'm unsocial I'm very odd with people so
what happens is I have replaced people
with work in my life because when I'm
working I would lot of people and there
are people I can interact with because
somewhere there is a wall that I'm not
interacting with them socially I'm
interacting them through this common you
know goal that is the work so I can
discuss with her or discuss with him and
we're friends for that moment many of my
filmmaking colleagues complained that
after the film is over you don't talk to
us I can't explain to them I don't have
anything else to say I love you I miss
you but i miss you through the work I
don't
I mean I'm very fond of a lot of people
a lot of people I love like family and I
I can't pick up the phone and talk with
them I can't socialize with them I can't
sit and chat with them but when we were
working I I can just be with them so I
don't know what it's sort of I have
replaced loneliness depression and
people would work
I'd like to be remembered as someone who
tried and tried very hard I'm always
trying
I always say tell my wife also even even
though there's a little book I'm writing
and I've written that please remember me
as someone who tried and tried very hard
whether I succeeded I don't want to be
remembered as did I fail I hope to god
I'm not remembered as that did I do well
or not is not important if people can
remember me as you know what he was a
trial he tried very hard
I don't mind some people turning out and
blaming me you know I think it's right
too hard he tries to a lot of people say
that he tries too hard that's ok but at
least I tried I'd like to be remembered
my legacy should be to my kids
especially I to be really honest if
people don't remember me otherwise it's
ok
I think they've given me enough but I'd
really would like my kids to remember me
as you know my dad he tried he tried
very hard in thank you guys so much for
watching we made this video because
spikes
21:08 asked us to if you have a famous
entrepreneur you'd like a video made of
leave a comment below
we'd also would love to know which of
the top 10 rules that you saw today I do
you like that pause I meant the most to
you okay keep going you can't keep going
you got to stop we're going to keep
going which rule meant the most to you
leave it at comments below and I will
join the discussion thank you so much
for watching continue to believe and
we'll see you soon I thought you're a
serious guy that was awesome